teddy bridgewater was officially
introduced yesterday he'll be the
starter at least for 2020
and pj walker previously known as philip
walker signed away from the xfl
yesterday was the day that teams could
begin signing xfl players and the best
player in the xfl star for the houston
roughnecks who were 5-0 before the xfl
had to shut down due to the covet 19
situation he is reunited with matt rule
who was with pj walker at temple now
he'll be in a position to compete to be
the backup to teddy bridgewater he did
some great things in the xfl chris i
know you didn't watch it your loss pj
walker was very very good running and
throwing the ball and it was just a
matter of time before he landed in the
nfl multiple teams were looking at him
the seahawks had multiple scouts at his
last game and the panthers with that
connection to matt rule reel him in
yeah i get it and you know you're right
i didn't watch xfl i watched pj walker
though there was a number of times where
you know i caught him on tv saw the
highlights you know certainly heard
about what he was doing you know he was
impressive even when he was you know
with the colts you know and pre-season
football he's got a quick release he
throws perfect spirals he's very
accurate and i think a lot of people
thought this would happen that he would
end up back with matt rule makes a lot
of sense he's got a similar skill set to
teddy bridgewater so that'll make for a
nice quarterback room uh but good for
b.j walker as a guy you know we like to
see those success stories a guy that
takes advantage of an opportunity that's
given to him he took it he was the star
of that league you know and hopefully he
or at least he hopes he can revive his
career in the nfl and get a chance to
play there at some point
another guy who had a decent season with
the xfl jordan ta'amu he has been signed
by the kansas city chiefs he'll have a
chance to compete to be on the depth
chart behind patrick mahomes and with
the carolina panthers picking up pj
walker chris they were able to unload
one of their quarterbacks a guy who
ultimately played in 13 games last year
with 12 starts kyle allen he gets sent
to washington reunites with former
panthers coach ron rivera and the
panthers get a fifth round pick for
their trouble that's not bad
when you undrafted when you sign a guy
undrafted and kyle allen and you can
flip him for a fifth round pick a couple
of years later if your new coaching
staff decides he's not going to fit with
what they're trying to do
no doubt well you know and we're seeing
you know coaches feel warm and cozy with
the people they know
matt rule signs pj walker yeah ron
rivera knows kyle allen you know scott
turner the offensive coordinator
coordinator there in washington he wants
to implement a system you need to have a
quarterback in the room in the building
that understands the system and can go
out and run practice be a tutor to
dwayne haskins at this point you know
listen i don't think kyle allen's coming
in here to like challenge dwayne haskins
as the starting quarterback but if
things fell apart for dwayne haskins now
you have a guy to sit here and go hey we
trust kyle allen he knows the offense he
played a lot last year he had some great
moments he really did you know i don't
think he's a starting quarterback
caliber type talent but i think kyle
allen is one of the better backups of
football now and into the future here
for a few years so makes a lot of sense
for the washington redskins and their
coaching staff
it makes me wonder where alex smith fits
in in the equation he has said he wants
to play
ron rivera has said don't rule out alex
smith you know and it feels like ron
rivera is a little ambivalent about
dwayne haskins i just wonder how this is
all going to play out in the coming
weeks and months especially if there's
no off season program for ron rivera to
get an early look at how alex smith is
performing if he's able to get on the
field how dwayne haskins looks how hard
is he working you know chris and and we
haven't delved down this rabbit hole yet
this morning but the more i think about
where we currently are in society and i
think about these group gatherings and
the facilities shut down if there's an
offseason program
the players are going to be in the same
solution situation that a lot of people
are right now which is they are going to
be working at home they're going to be
participating in meetings from home
they're going to be working out on their
own at home it's going to require a hell
of a lot of discipline it's going to be
a real test for younger players who may
be still in the process of maturing to
embrace everything they need to do
without being in that group that applies
via peer pressure and just presents the
impetus to do what you need to do you're
going to have to you're going to have to
prove to be a self-starter on a
consistent basis to get to where you
need to be in this off season program
yeah no it's not going to be easy for
players coaches anybody man i mean poor
new head coaches in the nfl trying to
implement your system you know with
nobody in the building the young
quarterbacks of the league like you're
mentioning that's going to be really
difficult you know hey yeah you can
learn through video conference face time
whatever it may be you can do all your
workouts you can go over to the field
and throw footballs but can you get
useful like walk through reps you know
the actual getting in the moment i'm in
the shotgun and i'm seeing the blitz
come and i've got to get the experience
of the walkthrough and the practice and
all of that
yeah players are going to miss that and
it's going to hurt the young players
more than anybody so
it's not going to be easy you're going
to see how these teams are going to
adjust i don't know how they're going to
do it but we saw it a little bit not too
long ago in the strike here we saw good
old jimmy harbaugh right my favorite
coach in football not uh but he had a
successful san francisco 49er team right
on a strike here and that's when he went
in with jim schwartz and gave him the
aggressive handshake because jim
schwartz had told them it was going to
be tough to have a successful year
without an off season so uh if jim
harbaugh can do it i'm saying anybody
can do it well schwartz took it farther
than that he was telling me you have no
chance just no chance why even bother
basically but here's the thing and this
is where teams need to be thinking
creatively they need to fashion an
offseason program that does indeed
embrace the technologies that are
available to ensure that guys are
engaged in these meetings that they are
teaching them effectively through their
web connections that they are working
out at home and that they are
accountable because you've got hundreds
of thousands of dollars in workout
bonuses that are tied to this as well so
yeah right while we're in this weird
state of limbo and it's not like the nfl
is going to make any announcements
prematurely on anything they plan to do
every team should be coming up with a
way to implement the offseason program
with all of their players at home
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports